one of the most troublesome aspects of
human nature is the fact that we always
divide the world into us versus them
pretty much every conflict we've seen
over human history involves some group
demarcated along some line via race
ethnicity country and so on
psychologists have really wanted to get
to the bottom of how we make these kinds
of distinctions you know where do these
different distinctions come from and how
can we get people to stop doing them so
we decided to study the origins of human
grouping by studying non-human primates
the species that we studied was rhesus
macaques teresa's macaques are an old
world monkey species that diverged from
humans 25 to 30 million years ago
they're a good test case for us to study
because they naturally form their own
social groups and because their groups
are flexible the monkeys that we studied
were a population on the island of Cayo
Santiago off the coast of Puerto Rico
Cayo Santiago is home to approximately
1,000 monkeys that free range around the
island these monkeys also naturally form
social groups so when we ran these
studies we found monkeys who were
hanging out on the island by themselves
we set up our stage in front of them our
stage consisted of a platform with two
screens on either end and the screens
covered up photos of other monkeys one
of whom was an in-group member and one
of whom was an out group member the
experimenter lifted the screens to
reveal both faces and monkeys were
allowed to freely watch them what we
were looking at was which face monkeys
were more worried about and which one
they stared longer at what we found was
that monkeys reliably seemed to look
longer at the out-group face suggesting
that they were more worried or more
scared of that one what this shows us is
that the capacity to distinguish between
members of different groups is not
unique to humans